nous apprenions hier que la secrétaire
d'état à l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes coanimera l'émission ballos
mon poste de cyril hanouna pourrais je
repense ses propos ramener des gens vers
le débat public
les français ne seraient ils pas les
français ne serait-il pas assez subtil
ou assez intelligent pour avoir besoin
de ce type d'émission pour réfléchir
pour comprendre et proposer monsieur le
premier ministre
elles savent être accord que madame
schiappa participent à ce talk show pour
le moins surprenant je vous remercie
pour votre question tout en veillant
c'est tout en nuance je vais essayer de
vous répondre sur le même ton
pardon mon étonnement mais je trouve
assez surprenante l'espèce de mise en
abyme dans laquelle vous nous plonger
parce que vous déplorez que l'on parle à
cyril hanouna et vous même vous
consacrer votre temps de parole au sénat
a parlé de cyril hanouna
ça me semble assez surprenant vous
auriez pu parler de sujets dits sérieux
comme par exemple la semaine les mets
fait dans la modération pour une fois
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui regardent
toutes les semaines l'émission de cyril
hanouna est ce que ces centaines de
milliers de personnes sont des citoyens
comme vous et moi
comme les gens qui écoutent france
culture comme les gens qui regardent
arte il n'y a pas de citoyen de seconde
zone madame la sénatrice le mépris de
classe le mépris de classe d'une
intelligence ya et d'une forme d'élites
politiques qui voudrait s'arroger la
seule responsabilité politique et la
seule capacité à accéder au débat
politique et au débat public
c'est ce mépris de classe qui a nourrit
en partie le mouvement des gilets jaunes
scheer qui en veut non seulement
gouvernement mais à l'ensemble de la
classe politique
je crois qu'on ne répond pas à des
problèmes politiques de 2019 avec des
solutions de 1999
ne vous en déplaise
vous avez mis le feu au pays en
s'entêtant sur une mesure dont personne
ne voulait une mesure préjudiciable pour
le quotidien des territoires sans pour
autant avoir une efficacité reconnue
je veux parler de 80 kilomètres heure
après six mois d'application
rien ne permet toujours d'affirmer que
la limitation à 80 a réduit le nombre de
tués sur les routes
le président de la république lors de
son tour de france propose de revenir
sur cette mesure et je cite trouver une
manière plus intelligente des solutions
plus pragmatique et faire quelque chose
qui soit plus acceptable alors monsieur
le premier ministre
envisagez-vous de reconsidérer votre
décision et trouver une solution
acceptable par tous envisagez vous de
suivre les propositions intelligentes du
sénat se débat il faudra avoir trois
choses en tête la première et vous nous
interroger sur l'efficacité de la mesure
et convient bien évidemment d'être
prudent mais selon les premiers chiffres
provisoires dont nous disposons sur ce
réseau secondaire entre le 1er juillet
2018 et le 31 décembre 2018 le nombre de
morts a baissé de 13% par rapport à
l'année 2017
deuxièmement il nous appartient il nous
appartiendra également de bien prendre
en compte les effets induits de cette
mesure
je pense notamment au temps de
déplacement je pense notamment aux
effets sur la consommation de carburant
ou encore sur la cohabitation entre les
voitures particulières et les poils au
nous avons demandé d'ailleurs pour
nourrir ce débat à la délégation
ministérielle à la sécurité routière
routière une étude sur ce point qui sera
bien sûr rendu public
[Musique]